hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i'm very excited
today because we had our first margin
call on amc so i'm gonna explain uh to
you guys why i think this is a margin
call i'm gonna explain again what i
showed you guys two days ago in my video
when i talked about correlation with the
global market and that the global
sell-off could trigger some margin calls
for hedges that are buying the deep and
i think that this is what is happening
and it is likely to continue so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right let's start guys with the
chart i have many things i want to show
you so this is amc chart so very quickly
guys uh one two three four five all
right elliot uh discovered 100 years ago
roughly a bit less that market developed
in five waves and here we have one two
three four i mean there's a fifth coming
it's really looking like this so then we
zoom in and we try to understand
how this fifth wave is gonna develop
probably in five waves we have
identified the first move up the second
move down here once again this is a
tricky market all right usually
let's say we have less fake outs in amc
we have a lot because of trading
algorithms that are running on this
market because there is a lot of money
involved there and those algorithms have
been calibrated to you know push you out
whenever it's uh time for them to
reload or to take some profits you know
this is how they work so here the
retracement level was the 78.6 percent
which is unusual for a second wave once
again
you can see this information here guys
and yet wave frost and pressure i've
shown you that many times but i will
keep showing you guys this because maybe
some of you are new it's important that
you are aware so i click on the third
link i go to the page 79 oh right and
here guys you have
you know the
kind of the retracement the usual
retracements the second wave usually go
to the 61.8 so we went slightly lower
which to be honest i didn't like
personally because we had here's so 61.8
was 38 and 38 was a strong support
so i i really wanted to hold above that
we faked out this is guys a typical fake
out so it probably got some traders out
of the trade and which is bad for them
but they are not apes for sure and here
we can see that we were close to the
breakup level right so the breakout
level is also a level that is usually
acting as support it was slightly higher
and 35 so basically we went to this area
and then guys look at what happened so
i'm on the fourth time frame so massive
volume massive move up guys this move up
it went
all right 22 up from the lows to the
highs relentlessly so what is it it's a
margin called
the way i see it uh i i checked the sp y
you can hear add compare and you you can
compare
two stocks between them so i'm gonna
choose here to keep this scale so i know
it's not easy to see but what is
interesting is here i'm on the 15
minutes time frame and i want to see i'm
going to use this vertical line to see
whenever the amc move up happened so
here you can see so this is yesterday's
session we started here so yesterday the
snp was just going lower
amc was going lower too and you can see
here guys we have this trend line okay
i don't know if you see it well let me
put it in blue
this trend line and it got broken guys
here look
this is the 15 minute time frame go
check it out guys it's very interesting
this is a beautiful example of how
financial markets are working and i'm
gonna show you again how to
find this information before it was
happening but first
break out of this mp500 here okay so
exactly at so let me
do the u.s time
all right so on the new york time it was
at guys the breakouts on the s p 500
occurred
at here okay at the lowest level on amc
amc was down 15
and we had the breakout and then guys
look
right after so the the volume is not
coming from here yet
but here we have suddenly so the volume
is picking up
snp 500 is diving and amc starts to go
higher and bomb here on this move down
all right so here there was still some
hope that the s p 500
goes back up and on this move down
here
so what is happening here i'm gonna
explain uh you can see that massive
volume and we
bounce back at 38 so here you can see
that the massive move up comes from the
re-test so guys hedge funds they know ta
right they know how it works so they
just bought the retest
so this move up destroyed everything
guys everything it's the biggest move up
i've seen for some time so it's very
very good for what's gonna come i'm
gonna give you my targets very soon
but you can see that here we destroyed
both resistances we went much higher and
then on the retest hedges both again and
maybe not only hedges maybe some you
know just long investors so this is
looking very good let me show you guys
this then i'm going to show you some
options that are interesting to make
here
so then i want to show you the
correlation so once again guys i've i've
shown that on jackson hunter's youtube
channel when i was live it was the first
time i was showing these results they
are very interesting so look
here i compute the one month the monthly
correlation between the returns of the s
p 500 spy and amc okay so roughly they
are positive fair enough but we can see
and in green i have the monthly return
of amc i just take monthly so that it
smoothes everything otherwise i just
have bars everywhere it's not readable
and we can see that mostly the
correlation which is here in blue and
you can see the coordination axis on the
left is mostly trading at positive
levels between zero
80 so roughly 50 but sometimes this
combination is going lower as here or
here or here
here here and maybe now and each time it
went lower look at the returns guys
going higher correlation lower returns
higher correlation lower much lower
returns much higher
correlation lower here returns a bit
lower but then higher so each time the
correlation drops
it triggers some massive moves up on amc
okay so this is what we know and look
where we are here we are here in terms
of correlation so roughly at the levels
where it's usually dropping roughly at
the levels where usually we start to
have this strong moves up coming you can
see that yesterday mc was up seven
percent s p was down one percent so the
correlation
which is here
uh dropped from 48
to 32
and we're gonna turn negative soon if
this continues so now let me show you
quickly uh my tier on the s p 500
because now you guys understand that
this is very linked i mean you knew
before right but now there is no more
doubt about that
so if this is linked
we can either do ta on amc which is some
of you say not working and i agree it's
tough because there are a lot of tricks
or do some ta on the spy which is much
easier so here on the spy guys if you
haven't seen that yet you can go and
check at this one or two videos update
about the sp y uh i gave you my view
when we had the first drop i'm bearish
guys for the coming month i think we're
going to keep dropping i'm going to
personally start to buy share at 420 400
so once again for those who interested
we are doing that in discord it's not
easy let's be honest we started to trade
uh here guys at the top of the market so
very tough markets we are still
overperforming the s p 500 which is what
we are trying to do here and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
reload massively guys whenever we are
lower it's not the right time for that
but anyway and amc i'm gonna show you as
well so here yeah first uh we broke out
guys some might see here very quickly on
on the spy
i have a few more fifth wave to come
that go much higher but right now we are
correcting we dropped from the wedge
pattern that was here we broke it
retested it and uh we are now moving
lower so we probably gonna lose
two or five more percent and if this
happens amc would probably skyrocket and
we have the breakout here on amc so ta
on spy is bearish ta on amc is bullish
and we know that whenever uh amc
strongly moves up the s p usually
strongly moves down so we have
everything guys here that is looking
good now let's go uh have a look first
on the synthetic shock interest so we
have a dtc of 1.6 100 million shares
traded yesterday but this is still high
i take the monthly dtc so the synthetic
shot is 6.7 once again i retrieved that
from the option market guys so here we
can see that we have some big strikes at
50
60 and 70 with a small delta once again
look at the delta seven percent four
percent three percent sixteen percent
twenty percent so if amc moves higher
this is going to create a lot of bullish
momentum market makers would need to buy
so we have hedges that are gonna buy
because hedges what do they do they
better deep on the market that's they
have always been doing
and
when you do that sometimes you just need
to cut your position at the first time
and
stop all of your other orders or
positions so you're gonna cut
what is still uh possible to save so
typically a short position on amc
so this is the reason why they are
cutting it it's because they buy the dip
on the rest of the market so just here
coming back to the synthetic short
interest so 6.7
the regular shot interest we don't know
it yet but it's 19 it might be lower now
because some margin calls have been
triggered so we're gonna analyze that uh
soon whenever the next data is released
i'm using 15th of september data so for
now we still uh not having new data to
use
and once again the bullish momentum is
at 50 60 70 so this is the levels where
we need to go for this fifth wave guys
to be really really happening so in this
fifth wave we are now playing the third
so i expect the third wave to go to the
70 maybe even higher depending on how
high we go we then gonna readjust the
target for now the target is 130 but of
course we can go much higher if things
really go wild that's it for me guys i
hope you enjoyed this video and i see
you very soon to discuss
the next move up on amc stay close to
shore